[Music]
[Music]
all right what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the conspiracy cuties
aka the conspiracy chicks today we're
gonna talk about Kanye West being my
next president Kanye West has this down
he knows what's going on mm-hmm
all right first and foremost his
platform is gonna be based on the movie
Black Panther yep which finally finally
finally somebody has an agenda I can get
behind
Kanye West is gonna be the first guy
who's gonna turn debates into what they
should be dis [ __ ] rap battle mixtape
fire hyena we just [ __ ] found them
super around through tik toks honor
everyone go delete their tik toks cuz
the Chinese are watching and it's a
planet divided from within I believe
that Kanye West tick tock and Shaun King
were hired by the Russians kanya is
gonna be the type of president that's
just gonna go you know what there's a
three-day workweek and everyone just
take the day off today it's a national
holiday and that's the type of president
I can get behind school lunches for
adults vote for Drake for the president
of Canada and the United States
seriously we have a combined president
of can we do that United States don't we
generally do that why did Kanye meet
with Trump in 2016 if this wasn't the
grand plan what were they talking about
[ __ ] college dropout so yeah he's
gonna split the black vote because
people are gonna vote for easy I mean he
calls himself black Jesus he's got my
vote cuz if you're bold enough to call
yourself Jesus yeah while Michael Jordan
is still walking around clothes out of
black Jesus I'm just gonna [ __ ] vote
for it Kanye is one of those guys he's
Fitz this podcast perfectly because for
him reality is a suggestion Kardashian
needs to be the next royal family from
now on our country is gonna be ruled by
celebrities only Ryan Donald Trump is
the first celebrity if you think for one
[ __ ] second we're ever going to elect
a politician again to drag us back into
these warts no we're gonna [ __ ] elect
celebrities Miley Cyrus 2028 Miley Cyrus
2020 Kanye Secretary of War is gonna be
Angie Shults and what it is in every
[ __ ] week every week you better sit
down in front of your TV for the [ __ ]
State of the Union and turn that TV to
the left
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching we
hope you loved it don't forget to click
subscribe and turn your alerts on and go
to patreon.com/crashcourse boyd's for
more fun where things get really limited
[Music]